fuerte apoyo social en contra del
fascismo en atenas el líder del partido
político amanecer dorado ya no tendrá
más poder el autodenominado grupo como
fascista en neonazi tuvo sus orígenes en
la década de 1980 su líder y fundador
nicos michal oli acuse quien
constantemente publicaba documentos en
contra de los refugiados está acusado de
presidir una organización criminal y de
asesinato de un cantante de rap opositor
en 2013 la condena fija una pena para él
de hasta 20 años de prisión el partido
político elogiaba a adolfo hitler y se
fijó como una agrupación nacionalista y
xenófoba que buscaba proteger los
empleos de los griegos en medio de la
crisis económica la gente de atenas está
dando su veredicto hoy no son inocentes
en la conciencia del pueblo griego es
una organización criminal e irá a donde
debe ir es decir al basurero de la
historia más de 60 miembros del partido
también fueron judicial izados por los
mismos cargos y dos individuos
resultaron absueltos miles de
manifestantes anti racistas se ubicaron
afuera de las instalaciones de la corte
en atenas para celebrar el veredicto y
benito en la voz asiática
la xxxiv o la wta mata muchas cosas van
a cambiar con esta decisión y azúcar y
toro las cosas mejoran o nos hundimos no
hay otro camino o mejoramos o nos
hundimos a la estaba jackson en 2014 en
medio de las elecciones locales el grupo
nazi obtuvo el apoyo de cerca de medio
millón de griegos lo cual le concedió 16
de las 300 sillas del parlamento sin
embargo para los comicios de 2019 el
partido político perdió todas sus bancas
con esta decisión la agrupación tenía
como lema sangre honor y amanecer dorado
tiene su sitio web bloqueado y se espera
la reacción de su líder quien no asistió
a la corte